la guerre Shakira piqué donc qui va en
sortir vainqueur
alors donc c'est la guerre je voudrais
je vous apprends rien ils ont divorcé du
footballeur rappelle sur la séparation
comment ça s'est passé un petit
doliprane à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a découvert que son mari l'a trompé
est résumé depuis le début Benoît à
cause de la confiture c'est à dire
qu'elle partait en vivant ensemble donc
il vivait ensemble donc dans le foyer
familial quand elle rentrait de ses
tournées ou de ses prestations elle
rentre chez elle il y avait de la
confiture dont son mari n'aura pas et ça
diminuait sa diminue du coup elle en
mangeant
après en vidéo en vidéo des mots sur son
ordinateur et ce sont aperçus après par
la suite qui avait une jeune fille qui
passait de 25 ans donc de moins 20 ans
moins qu'elle et là elle s'est aperçu de
tout ça et comme quoi il a trompé
l'histoire
génial alors autre résumé Florian ici la
confiture c'est vrai et c'est ce qui lui
a fait enclencher le l'embout de
détective privé d'accord effectivement
elle a eu des choses très claires mais
en fait la vérité c'est que Piqué a
rencontré une nana de 23 ans dans une
soirée il y a eu selon leurs proches un
vrai coup de foudre il y a eu adultère
pendant quelques mois elle bossait pour
lui jusqu'à qu'elle finisse par
découvrir le poteau rose ils se sont
séparés au début ça allait à peu près
puis ça a dégénéré depuis quelques temps
c'est la guerre on l'a vu faisant une
sorte de doigt d'honneur à destination
de son ex lors d'un match de baseball de
leur fils il y a une chanson qui vient
de sortir
trois chansons mais surtout une qui
cartonne jeudi dernier sur Youtube et
puis de 50 millions de vues en moins de
24 heures et euh
au plus haut point mais elle est de plus
elle est d'autant plus irçue qu'elle
regardait tout à fait par hasard une
interview qu'il avait donné lui il y a
plusieurs mois et que derrière on
voit-il la fameuse jeune fille le 23 ans
déjà alors écoutez la chanson
ce qui va tout déclencher regarde
dis-moi ça faisait 10 mois
[Musique]
donc on a expliqué juste avant pourquoi
il s'est séparé c'est évidemment Piqué
qui a fait comme souvent l'homme qui a
fait des conneries qui l'a trompé ouv
rendu compte mais ça aurait pu en rester
là parce qu'ils avaient décidé pour le
bien de leurs deux enfants de garder ça
dans les dans le domaine du raisonnable
ils avaient même demandé à la presse de
pas s'en mêler etc il voulait rester
tranquille et sauf qu'ils avaient signé
une convention devant notaire disant
qu'il ne devait pas s'afficher avec une
autre fille ou garçon elle a un garçon
fille pendant un an pour respecter une
sorte de période de deuil et
malheureusement trois semaines à voir si
cette convention il était un smash de
foot il a roulé des pelles devant tout
le monde et une fille et là du coup elle
a trahison voilà à la séparation des
l'humiliation et là du coup elle a
décidé de déclarer la guerre et aussi
ses chansons pour le matraquer elle lui
a piqué et c'est dur en plus pour une
fille on vous quitte pour 20 ans de
moins hein donc évidemment je suis un
peu précise un tout petit truc c'est que
il la quitte pour une nana qui a 10 ans
de moins que lui parce que lui il est
beaucoup plus jeune que il a 10 ans de
moins qu'elle donc finalement ce qui
fait avec cette nouvelle nana c'est ce
qu'elle faisait avec lui il a 10 ans de
moins oui enfin l'inverse
non mais parce que je précise là ou rien
c'est juste qu'elle l'attaque entre
autres sur la différence d'âge la
différence d'âge n'est pas un sujet
voilà est-ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'en général quand quelqu'un
trompe sa femme pour être avec vous
dites-vous qu'en général disons après
vous serez le prochain donc la première
fois visiblement puisqu'il y avait eu
des rumeurs à un moment comme quoi il
l'a trompé avec barafaeli il y a voilà
alors la réponse du piquet qui a répondu
à Shakira alors que chez quelqu'un lui a
reproché à être passé du Ferrari une
twingo en passant dès à sa copine
actuelle bah regardez comment justement
d'ailleurs que pub de l'année meilleur
que pub de l'année pour Renault
il est arrivé avec une Renault
meilleur coup de pic de l'année pour
Renault c'est gigantesque cette histoire
qui l'offre évidemment la bagnole et
comme elle a dit aussi tu m'as acheté
une Rolex contre une Casio bah qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait c'est ça
c'est des contrats
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce qui est drôle c'est que Casio qui
joue très très bien un coup de marketing
a fait un communiqué en disant on va
peut-être pas les Rolex mais au moins on
nous garde toute notre vie c'est génial
non non génial et les deux du coup on
fait plein de blés
ça va encore plus loin parce que chaque
ira du cas du coup elle mais cette
histoire elle est elle place sur sa
terrasse une sorcière il faut que je
sache qu'elle habite en face de son ex
la mère de piquet habite en face
[Rires]
il faut savoir surtout
ce qu'il faut savoir surtout c'est
qu'ils sont extrêmement superficieux et
que tout ce qui est sorcière etc pour
eux attire le mauvais œil et elle a fait
comme on dit chez moi je mette elle a
fait exprès elle a mis devant devant
elle et toute la journée elle écoute son
disque à fond pour que tout le monde
entendait que ça belle-mère entendu on
n'a pas la vidéo
à fond dans le quartier voilà la vidéo
un truc important que ce qu'on rigole
c'est quand même super triste parce
qu'ils ont deux enfants ensemble qui
assiste à ça que ce soit la chanson les
répliques de piquer sans parler du fait
que la presse people et le tableau de
monde entier pendant un an voilà c'est
je trouve que leur petit jeu chanson etc
je sais pas si ça fait rire leurs autres
enfants qui sont dans la même situation
et qui souffre j'ai pas le temps est-ce
que les parents font un sketch
médiatique
[Rires]